bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette vidéo
week-end comme tous les vendredis nous
allons faire le point sur les
rendez-vous loisirs qui vous attend nous
allons parler de deux animations trap
plage et puis les API les animations
d'immeubles alors les API c'est un peu
partout en France et notamment à
Guyancourt mes invités pour ce vendredi
à l'irabet bonjour vous êtes mère
adjoint un trappe en charge de la
jeunesse cet homme lui ont dit bonjour
vous êtes responsable du service
jeunesse de la vie de Guyancourt et
également déléguer à l'urbanisme à la
ville de Trappes vous connaissez
forcément tous les deux voilà on va
démarrer avec vous à l'irabet trap plage
c'est depuis le 7 juillet jusqu'au 14
août au complexe sportif Jacques
Moncourt on se dit qu'avec le temps
qu'il fait depuis ce lundi il y a pas
grand monde ça c'est un peu
et la météo ça démarre pas sur les
chapeaux de roue ceci dit c'est la
sixième édition chaque année on reçoit
autour de 10 000 personnes 9000 l'année
dernière on a eu également des années
avec un très beau temps on est monté à
plus de 10000 familles qui ont fréquenté
le traplage on espère que
vous avez plusieurs pôles bon évidemment
la piscine le complexe sportif Jacques
monco avec la la grande piscine qui
permet d'accueillir les familles qui
permet la baignade au mois d'août et au
mois de juillet vous avez également des
pôles autour pour les familles pour les
enfants avec les projets interservice
qui associe à la fois la petite enfance
les centres culturels qui émettent à
disposition leurs animateurs et qui
préparent des animations vous avez
également le service jeunesse qui est
immobilisé plus de 30 agents sur la
piscine et le complexe sportif vous avez
à la fois un solarium qui permet aux
familles de bronzer profiter du beau
temps quand on en a mais vous avez
également des animations toute la
journée en particulier le soir pour les
enfants les familles toute la journée
plusieurs semaines d'affilée vous avez
des semaines thématisées la première
semaine c'est la thématique
le Brésil après après le score de lundi
dernier qui a éliminé l'équipe de foot
mais malgré tout c'est la Semaine Brésil
donc vous avez des animations autour de
la samba de la capoeira vous avez un
tournoi de beach soccer en sortant
d'animation qui permet de mettre la
plage aux couleurs du Brésil pendant la
première semaine vous avez la thématique
enquête policière la seconde semaine la
troisième on fait une animation autour
de Koh-Lanta avec des jeux de chasse au
trésor sur la plage la cinquième semaine
vous avez de l'astronomie ensuite vous
avez une semaine thématisée interview
avec une olympiade un blind test autour
de la musique et vous avez en dernière
semaine à la thématique des super-héros
qui va nous permettre de faire tourner
un petit peu l'animation les décors et
de donner du plaisir à toutes les
générations alors en cas de policière
Koh-Lanta qu'est-ce qui te trouve toutes
ces idées les animateurs
hommage à leur travail c'est il y a peu
de villes qui réussissent à faire
fonctionner leur service en
inter-service donc à mettre tout le
monde très en amont autour de la table a
inventé des thématiques et inventer des
animations on tire également les
conclusions de ce qui s'est bien déroulé
les années précédentes ou de ce qui a pu
être défaillant et on propose une des
améliorations chaque année en
concertation également avec les jeunes
et les pratiquants quel que soit leur
âge pour essayer d'améliorer d'année en
année les les offres à la population et
ça veut dire c'est ouvert au niveau des
âges tous les âges
des plus petits qui viennent accompagner
obligatoirement de leurs parents
jusqu'aux adolescents qui ont droit des
passes adolescents et qui fréquentent le
club ado donc le service lyonnaise de la
ville les encadre et ensuite vous avez
également tous les adultes qui peuvent
venir librement
bronzés profiter de la plage et des
animations et vous dites on tire les
leçons des années précédentes ce qui est
bien normal ça veut dire qu'il y a des
nouveautés cette année il y a des
changes chaque année il y a
systématiquement des nouveautés il y a
des animations qui ont réussi on peut
les reconduire d'autres qui fonctionnent
un petit peu moins on maintient les
conséquences mais globalement chaque
année on renouvelle les thématiques pour
que ce soit pas toujours la même offre à
la population à qui sont réservés ces
activités est-ce que c'est il faut être
uniquement trappiste pour y aller pour
accéder gratuitement à attrapage parce
que tout ça est gratuit il faut
effectivement résider à Trappes donc on
demande pour l'inscription une
attestation d'habitation à trappe et une
carte d'identité alors si on n'est pas
trappiste et qu'on veut venir profiter
on peut ou pas assez réservé vraiment
vraiment au trappiste combien tout
d'animateurs mobilisés vous avez tous
les services
une trentaine d'animateurs est-ce que en
dehors de trap plage qui est vraiment le
gros événement sur l'été sur la ville de
Trappes est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
événements aussi bien sûr vous savez
qu'en France on a autour de 3 millions
de familles qui ne partent pas de 3
millions d'enfants pardon qui ne partent
pas en vacances donc on déploie toute
une palette d'activités pour que les
jeunes puissent profiter de leur mois de
juillet de leur mois d'août on a trois
saisons notamment qui vont faire partir
des jeunes de la ville loin de Trappes
pour pouvoir profiter de leur congés un
en Auvergne dans le Jura et un Normandie
et on a également un nouveau dispositif
qui s'appelle cultive ta culture c'est
la deuxième édition qui nous permet de
d'emmener des jeunes et de les préparer
à la rentrée scolaire à la fin du mois
d'août dans un séjour dans le Jura donc
dans un cadre exceptionnel où ils
peuvent reprendre l'habitude des temps
scolaires commencent à travailler à
reprendre le rythme du travail pour
retourner à l'école plus naturellement à
la rentrée mais sur ce type de centre de
centre de vacances en centre est-ce
qu'il y a des je sais pas ça part avec
des professeurs avec des instituteurs
qui ont un niveau de diplôme qui permet
d'encadrer des groupes et notamment sur
le travail éducatif c'est à chaque fois
50 de jeunes qui partent en car on a
quatre séjours donc vous voyez que
plusieurs centaines
on essaye de répondre aux besoins mais
les séjours sont tellement prisés parce
que c'est un vrai succès avec les
familles qui ont envoyé un premier
enfant veulent envoyer le second quand
il constate la qualité des prestations
on a des listes d'attente effectivement
sauf qu'on comprend dans les animations
d'été c'est qu'à la fois effectivement
il y a un côté ludique il y a aussi un
petit côté de lien social non seulement
je vous ai parlé de l'aspect éducatif de
ces séjours mais évidemment l'objectif
c'est de faire du lien c'est que les
habitants qui se côtoient peu tout au
long de l'année on a des fêtes de
quartier il y a la fête des voisins qui
fonctionnent pas mal on a notamment
récemment vous avez peut-être eu
l'occasion de découvrir cela une
animation dans un quartier organisé par
des jeunes alors neuf jeunes qui ont
pris l'initiative et qui rassemble plus
de 1000 personnes aujourd'hui donc
faites des voisins il y avait beaucoup
de monde
plus de 800 repas servis donc on
multiplie ce type de d'animation dans la
commune aussi bien dans la ville
elle-même dans chaque quartier
au complexe sportif Jacques Moncaut pour
trap plage mais également l'extérieur ça
permet d'emmener parfois plus en
générations des mamans des papas des
enfants des plus petits qui partent dans
un seul car et qui découvrent la vie en
société avec leurs voisins leurs amis à
l'autre bout de la France ce que vous
dites rendre les jeunes acteurs
effectivement ils sont acteurs par le
biais de cette manifestation central
plage aussi les jeunes peuvent être
acteurs ils peuvent organiser des
ateliers ils sont sollicités
du service si on parle des jeunes en
particulier mais il y a pas que des
jeunes intra-plage mais les jeunes
globalement sont associés par le service
lyonnaise à l'ensemble des activités qui
sont mises en place leur avis compte à
chaque fois qu'on a des jeunes qui
proposent d'organiser on leur tend la
main et on les accompagne on met à
disposition des moyens et compris sur
trappe là j'effectivement dans la
construction des animations on peut les
associer merci
jusqu'au 14 août au complexe sportif
Jacques monco c'est gratuit mais ce
n'est réservé qu'aux trappistes voilà et
c'est ouvert du lundi au dimanche à des
horaires un petit peu différent on va
maintenant parler des appuis c'est les
animations pieds d'immeubles qui ont
lieu à Guyancourt les premières habits
on aura quatre en tout sur estivale à
Guyancourt ça se déroule ce vendredi 17
et samedi 18 à partir de 15h30 j'ai dit
une erreur janvier vendredi 17 et 18
pour les premières pays d'accord
jeudi 17 et vendredi 18 d'accord jeudi
et vendredi donc à partir de 15h30
omae des saules côté de la Roseraie
anne-mariedou pour être exactement
précisé dans le quartier de Villaroy
c'est quoi ces apps alors les API alors
les premières applis auront lieu
effectivement le 17 et 18 juillet pour
la première fois enfin pour les
premières apps mais à mono alors je
préfère rétablir comme ça les gens ne se
tromperont pas de lieu alors en quoi ça
consiste effectivement par d'un constat
qui est que beaucoup de jeunes ne
partent pas forcément en vacances donc
c'est de plus en plus le cas avec la
crise pour lutter contre cette fracture
de jeunes qui ne peuvent pas non plus
travailler pour certains pour lutter
contre l'oisiveté donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de d'aller au plus près des
habitants d'un quartier
se concentre pas que sur des jeunes on
va le voir mais proposer des animations
au pied d'immeuble happy donc qui existe
au niveau national beaucoup de villes
font ça mais chacun se l'approprie
différemment alors nous sur sur
Guyancourt ce qu'on a souhaité c'est
effectivement mettre à contribution les
jeunes dans un premier temps qu'il soit
vraiment acteur ce qu'on disait
effectivement et valable aussi sur
Guyancourt c'est-à-dire que en rendant
les jeunes acteurs ont permis aux jeunes
de participer d'être acteur et puis on
fait la citoyenneté par la même c'est à
dire que
là les appuis c'est surtout alors là on
voit par exemple l'exemple des applis
qui avait eu au Clayes-sous-Bois parce
que c'est quelque chose effectivement
qui a lieu un peu partout il y a des
animations qui sont mises en place en
général c'est vraiment très ludique en
quoi interviennent les jeunes ils sont
ils tiennent les ateliers ils organisent
stands alors effectivement on permet en
fait de proposer une trame aux habitants
qui est des structures gonflables des
animations avec des associations qui
s'investissent aussi on fait appel
beaucoup aux associations donc on a des
initiations initiations pardon taekwondo
notamment et on propose des activités
des animateurs jeunesse eux-mêmes
proposent des standards mais l'idée
c'est que ces animateurs en fait laisse
la place progressivement vers le jeûne
et que on se retrouve à la fin des API à
des stands qui sont tenus par les jeunes
ce qui s'est passé l'an passé on a eu
presque 1200 personnes qui sont passées
un véritable succès où on a vu des
jeunes et tracteurs alors au-delà de ça
on est aussi des jeunes qui sont déjà
qui essayent déjà de se structurer
qu'elle soit par le biais associatif ou
bien par le biais d'un investissement
quelconque sur la ville
vous voulez dire quoi
en association soit qui souhaitent se
mettre en association parce qu'on est
déjà sur une étape supérieure en termes
de structuration pour les jeunes en tout
cas et certains viennent avec des idées
alors nous à nous de pouvoir recevoir
ces idées et puis de les aider les
accompagner vers la mise en place
d'action et on se retrouve par exemple
avec cette année l'association
promouvoir qui est une association qui a
à peu près un an qui s'est créé à peu
près un an ces jeunes étaient venus sur
les API de l'an passé et ce sont créant
l'association et puis maintenant on a
des jeunes qui sont proposants qui
viennent avec des idées et puis on les
reçoit ils vont faire des crêpes un
petit tournoi de foot voilà on essaye
vraiment d'accompagner tout ça donc
autour du côté ludique la même question
que la mirabelle il y a c'est vraiment
le but c'est de créer du lien social de
rencontrer montrer peut-être des jeunes
et des habitants qui ont peut-être pas
l'habitude de forcément vous voyez pas
dans les associations alors c'est
exactement le deuxième objectif que
propose les applis c'est à dire que il y
a le participatif on vient de le voir et
il y a le côté intergénérationnel
c'est-à-dire que on se rend compte que
les jeunes n'ont pas besoin enfin ont
besoin aussi de contact avec des aînés
des plus jeunes et puis de pouvoir aussi
se faire valoriser et par ce biais on se
rend compte que dans un quartier ça
avait été évoqué juste avant les gens se
côtoient que très rarement quand on
propose des applis alors là en
l'occurrence ces deux jours consécutifs
sur quatre temps défini tout au long des
vacances et ben les habitants sortent de
chez eux et on se rend compte que ils
sont très demandeurs on finit
généralement le vendredi avec une
animation particulière ça peut être par
le biais par exemple d'une soirée
musicale un temps musical effectivement
ou alors une projection de cinéma et on
finit avec un repas partagé alors le
principe du repas partagé est très
simple chaque habitant vient avec un
plat un dessert une entrée et on met
tout en fait en commun et on se retrouve
avec des grandes tablés
facile effectivement et puis qui permet
tout au long de l'été de garder un
rythme un rythme de contact de d'échange
et de chaleur entre les gens vous l'avez
dit il y en a quatre il y aura quatre
appuis sur toute la ville donc là ça
commence avec le quartier de Villeroy
quel autre quartier sont concernés alors
ensuite on se retrouve à Cosma le 24 et
25 juillet on enchaînera ensuite à
Renoir donc côté Saul Park près de la
fac de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on sera
aux alentours du 21 22 août et on finit
le 28 29 août avec pasteur le pont du
routoir avec la projection de cinéma
donc créer de la convivialité rencontrer
les habitants ça permet aussi de régler
des petits conflits de voisinage des
choses comme ça non c'est pas du tout
fait pour ça alors des voisins c'est
connu ça permet des fois de se dire les
choses qu'on ne se dit pas le reste de
l'année mais c'est plus sympa de se dire
les choses devant une salade et regarde
ça peut avoir cette vertu pour l'instant
je l'ai pas en tout cas moi je l'ai pas
vu en tout cas sachez que ce jour là le
plus important c'est qu'on puisse
valoriser aussi bien les jeunes dans
leur implication les familles et puis on
se retrouve avec des gens qui sont très
volontaires qui ont qui sont en attente
en fait de ce genre d'animation sont
partenaires Guyancourt des applis qui
ont certaines communes sont partenaires
alors là où ils peuvent être partenaires
en tout cas en ce qui nous concerne
c'est sur la communication effectivement
on met une communication sur l'ensemble
des des bâtiments et avec la valve bien
sûr des bailleurs en l'occurrence c'est
pour une meilleure communication et puis
que chacun puisse avoir l'information et
on le sait l'information c'est le
premier degré de l'implication
alors on est sur le sur le service
jeunesse en tout cas une on est 10
animateurs environ mais vous avez
au-delà de ça des associations qui
viennent notamment la carte
guyancourtoise on a promouvoir des
jeunes associations de taekwondo aussi
tennis de table etc donc on a des
encadrants à la fois animateurs bafa
mais on a aussi des jeunes qui
s'impliquent qui sont du coup
responsable d'un stand des associations
et puis des habitants ce qu'on se
retrouve le soir avec un repas environ
400 personnes chaque repas et chaque
maman papa qui souhaite s'investir vient
et tient et le buffet organise le
service participe passé de mobiliser
alors ça donne en plein été les gens
peuvent partir en vacances
ce comporte pas en vacances pas
forcément envie de s'impliquer alors le
triste constat c'est qu'on se retrouve
quand même avec beaucoup de monde j'ai
envie de dire triste parce que ça veut
dire que beaucoup de gens ne partent pas
en vacances c'est surtout ça la
tristesse du constat après au-delà de ça
ce que ça montre c'est que chacun a
envie de s'impliquer pour se retrouver à
400 sur un repas partagé ça donne
vraiment une ambiance particulière dans
un coeur de quartier ça veut dire qu'il
y a vraiment une demande et un besoin
est-ce que je voudrais l'été c'est
vraiment une période de crispation quand
même assez social assez particulière
c'est une ambiance assez particulière
entre tous ces gens malheureusement qui
ne peuvent pas partir en vacances ce qui
est une attention particulière qui est
portée sur cette période j'ai pas de
mécaniquement de la crispation pendant
l'été au contrôle je reconnais mais
effectivement il y a souvent du
désœuvrement et le rôle des pouvoirs
publics le rôle des municipalités c'est
de lutter contre le désordrement en
veillant à ce que le public puisse
trouver à s'épanouir dans des activités
proposées de qualité encore une fois
c'est important qu'on ne propose pas
juste de l'occupationnel juste de
proposer de donner des clés d'une salle
et de laisser les gens se brouiller mais
de construire avec eux des projets de
qualité les applis qui se passent à
Guyancourt ça se passe aussi à Trappes
tout à l'heure du quartier des jeunes
qui l'organisent qui organise un certain
nombre d'autres animations de la même
nature mais des tremplins de musicaux
etc mais on organise pas les animations
de pays meubles sous la même forme
chacun a ses spécificités d'accord merci
en tout cas à vous d'être venu sur toute
cette week-end donc on oublie personne
pendant l'été
tu peux en profiter juste pour vous dire
que aussi donc durant toutes les
vacances on propose sur Guyancourt
beaucoup d'activités pour les jeunes
alors là on a le retour d'un groupe de
jeunes qui est parti en Ardèche un petit
séjour merveilleux qu'ils ont eux-mêmes
concocté et donc on aura des stages de
street dance de court-métrage des
activités des sorties à la base de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin et donc de
trappes et on profite voilà de ce temps
pour construire des projets qui seront
pérenne sur l'année prochaine aussi donc
on implique dès les vacances les jeunes
donc tout un programme d'activité
jeunesse à la fois sur la ville de
Guyancourt à la fois sur la ville de
Trappes merci en tout cas vous êtes
revenu sur le plateau de cette suite
weekend allez on passe maintenant à
l'actualité de la semaine écoulée
et cette semaine l'École Municipale des
Sports d'Élancourt à organiser un stage
de tennis et d'athlétisme l'occasion
pour les jeunes de découvrir des
disciplines et peut-être d'avoir l'envie
ensuite de s'inscrire dans un club
Anthony Rech Jonathan Wilman
si la tenue de raquette est encore
hésitante ces jeunes joueurs découvrent
avec plaisir le tennis j'ai déjà fait de
la voile mais je trouve que c'est mieux
de faire du tennis et de l'athlétisme
comme ça ça m'apprend à courir déjà et
j'apprends mieux à taper dans la balle
avec une raclette lors de ce stage de
l'École Municipale des Sports les cours
de tennis sont encadrés par un
professeur du club élancourtois
l'athlétisme par une éducatrice de la
commune ce n'est pas en une semaine que
l'on devient un champion de la balle
jaune mais au bout de cinq jours de
stage chacun est capable d'être autonome
sur le terrain les tous premiers
conseils c'est d'essayer de faire de
jouer en partenariat parce que eux tout
de suite ils sont surtout très
compétitions les garçons après les
filles elles sont plutôt on est chez
avec ma copine d'accord mais alors on
essaie de jouer d'abord en partenariat
et puis ensuite pour les garder
éveillées parce que sinon ils partent
dans tous les sens c'est essayer de
faire des matchs des points des petits
défis voilà etc
à l'extérieur l'autre groupe d'enfants
cessait au saut en longueur après avoir
découvert le lancer ces jeunes sportifs
essaient toutes les facettes de
l'athlétisme l'objectif leur donner le
goût de discipline parfois méconnu
l'idée c'est de leur faire découvrir une
activité sportive donc l'athlétisme
toutes les composantes de l'athlétisme
course sur Lancer et l'idée c'est de les
initier et puis de les intéresser pour
éventuellement plus tard les orienter
vers les clubs ici il n'y a pas de
compétition au détour de quelques
échanges naissent parfois des amitiés au
total c'est 32 enfants bénéficient de 15
heures de sport sur 5 jours pour
seulement 32 euros
jusqu'à samedi le festival remettait-on
propose des ateliers créatifs aux petits
de manière idéale pour rencontrer des
princesses et des objets roulants non
identifiés aux manettes Olivier
Maniscalco et elodiemoine
malgré le temps il flotte comme un
parfum de vacances au quartier du
Buisson depuis lundi le festival
remettait donc propose aux enfants de
Manille et hameaux de nombreux ateliers
et jeux aussi sympathiques que ludiques
capoeira potri et masque ou instrument
bizarroïde les petits font parler leur
créativité comme ici sur le stand de
fabrication de costumes
bah elle a dit qu'on ferait un haut avec
des espèces de non je veux dire des
chiffons et après on a une machine à
coudre pour coudre et
tu vas pouvoir trouver un prince
charmant
non loin des princesses un autre atelier
propose de créer son objet roulant non
identifié et déjà un gros orni hors de
l'entrée un oiseau tombé de son nid un
gros orni donc c'est un perroquet comme
on est sur le thème du Brésil on avait
choisi de faire un animal qui est
représentatif donc le perroquet donc
c'est simple on est en principe partie
sur une base à roulettes on a fixé les
arceaux après par dessus du grillage
pour donner forme et puis maintenant on
est sur la phase où on colle le papier
quoi le laisser para l'imagination les
laisser travailler enfin pas de s'en
donner directive leur donner un cadre
depuis que derrière ce cadre puisse
s'épanouir tout simplement
pour sa cinquième édition remettait ton
gars réunis près de 1000 enfants par
jour samedi un défilé des plus belles
créations se tiendra devant l'estaminet
avant la diffusion dimanche de la finale
du Mondial suivi du traditionnel feu
d'artifice
un temps plus vieux en cette fin de
semaine du mieux pour ce week-end n'est
pas encore les grandes chaleurs alors
l'occasion peut-être d'aller au ciné vos
avis les éclairer de spectateurs au
micro dès l'audimoine un très beau film
sur l'intégration dans l'ancien filmé
très bien joué j'ai particulièrement
apprécié le jeu des acteurs et bien
c'est bien fait c'est sympa il y a de
l'humour vraiment c'est bien c'est avoir
vraiment c'est bien il y a de l'action
en plus c'est pas mal
que c'était une bonne idée surtout de
faire un film comme ça il était bien
et
je dirais longtemps aussi moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé
ça rappelle un petit peu les
notre jeunesse ces années
j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est très bien c'est
oui c'est amusant il s'est touchant à la
fois voilà et pour terminer ce 7 8
week-end un petit passage par la case
agenda les festivités du 13 juillet on
va commencer à Guyancourt avec la fête
nationale qui sont placée sous le signe
de la zumba dimanche 13 juillet à partir
de 23h au lac de Villaroy au menu un
spectacle pyrotechnique autour donc de
la zumba suivi d'un bal populaire de 23h
à 1h du matin avec l'orchestre club 667
pour les amateurs de l'orchestre les
communes de Voisins-le-Bretonneux et
Montigny-le-Bretonneux s'associe comme
chaque année autour du lac de la
Sourderie cela débutera alors par un bal
à 21h un feu d'artifice à 23h et à
nouveau un bal à 23h30
attrape toujours le 13 à
Magny-les-Hameaux cette fois pardon un
bal sera proposé dès 19h sur l'esplanade
Philippe suivi à 21h de la diffusion de
la Coupe du monde sur écran géant et
d'un feu d'artifice à 23h30
voilà trap plage maintenant n'oubliez
pas non plus l'opération trap plat
jusqu'au 14 août au complexe sportif
Jacques monco des activités de vacances
vous seront proposés lundi du lundi au
dimanche avec des horaires différents
vous pouvez découvrir sur ce cartouche
la diffusion de la Coupe du Monde c'est
également à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux sur gymnase Alain
Colas et peut-être pour finir
pour finir du sport avec du football
américain elle en cours demi-finale et
finale de la Champions League américaine
européenne pardon cela démarre vendredi
final à 17h dimanche 4 équipes en lice
et l'encours et zinsky Thonon-les-Bains
et Belgrade Guy Boniface Élancourt voilà
pour ce week-end ah bon et voilà la fête
nationale la fête nationale attrape ces
dimanches 13 juillet à 23h et le feu
d'artifice qui sera retiré près du Maine
laqueduc voilà pour toutes ces infos du
7 8 weekends c'est maintenant terminé
merci votre attention c'était la
dernière émission de la saison très bel
été à vous et rendez-vous en septembre